what is up everybody welcome back to
another business Q&A while we play
League of Legends
I am queueing up with my I think every
every game we played with with fresh
fuse who was Jay Rhys Jason Grif on Sica
so we're queuing up for a game together
and it's the return of the cup
hashtag return of the cup is amazing
return of the couple is that I said that
is truly amazing return of the cup is
truly amazing
yeah absolutely
this is song return of the cup write
something else but we'll go is return of
the cup anyway
Rishi TV dragon has all right we had
Super Sunday
Jennifer pricing yesterday and she's
down with us today so let's go through a
receipt what's in the cup okay well just
to start I've got my cup of Spanish
coffee as usual this morning and I have
got a cup of now wait for it wait before
wait for the quote before you think it's
that a bad cup a cup of failure okay
yeah and my quote for today is from Bill
Gates and it and he says it's fine to
celebrate success but it is more
important to heed the lessons of failure
so yeah I just wanted to remind everyone
this morning that your mistakes are are
valuable like your success and that's it
Bill Gates Bill Gates saved my business
saved my business
I'm a big fan mmm-hmm cool well I have
what do I have my usual
little T in a Minnie Mouse Cup today my
vitamin water my water my protein drink
Nina gave me a cup of two eggs that need
to go through and eat those and at some
point I'll have a cup of coffee as well
but it's not ready yet so I'm excited
reaches back
I mean we're laughing yes we're laughing
in the chat Evan because we realized
that a rise put in the chat the song is
return of the Mack and I seconds ago
this is the new improved version new
improved version this how was meant to
be recorded is returned to the cup we're
bringing it back 26 Wow amazing
the original love it all right well I am
plain support I'm gonna lock in my team
Oh soon
Jay Rhys is doing his heimer bottom soar
experiment continues that we started
yesterday and let's get into the first
question oh my god let's help so much
foreigners good nice and just a
shout-out to Rhys online off to
sourcebook damata all in the house today
alright and our first question is coming
from did the June James and the June
James had a follow-up question in
regards to your video called patent an
idea how to get a patent without
spending a lot of money great video for
those interested on money more about
patents and she says that I enjoyed your
video I have product I have a product
that I need to get patented but I do not
have the resources at this time I would
like to find some investors that could
fund my patent and in return I could
offer them one to five percent of my
profit what would be the best way to
find investors okay good deal I'd love
to hear even when you when you respond I
didn't I'm wondering if if investment
into patents is part of what investors
would actually be interested in because
yeah I I think if they do if an investor
really is interested in investing in the
patent aspect of your of your invention
or your idea they're going to want to
see that there is proof you know that
this product actually is going to be a
profitable business so the first thing
would be just you'd have to have some
testing that this is actually a product
that people want and and that's what's
going to invest that's what an investor
is going to be interested in is is it
really proven that this is a product
that people want and that will be
profitable in regards to what's the best
way to find an investor we talked about
in a previous episode how investors you
know they don't go around saying hey
yeah I'm an investor come talk to me
about your idea unless of course you
apply for Shark Tank but other than that
they are just you know regular people
out in the world that you with a little
bit of asking and and chatting maybe to
friends finding out in your network that
there might be people who would be
interested you know Evan I think talked
about you know your dentist or an
accountant friend or you know just
someone that you may already know who is
and
and just requires a little bit of
looking into your network to find out
maybe potential investors but again I
think the most important thing is where
you go to that step you really want to
know that you've you really tested and
proven your concept that it is something
that people want and that networks there
you go I was peeling an egg well while
you went on that I liked that was
enjoyable ah seeing it seeing it yep
okay so first of all if you're working
off of intellectual property kind of
deal you're likely gonna do something
around revenue not profit one the 5% of
profit is nothing no no inverse is gonna
go for that they're gonna they're gonna
want a revenue deal they're gonna want a
royalty of what is sold in terms of
being able to go up and get the investor
on board though this is not the kind of
thing that most investors are interested
in investors don't want to go out and
just fund the patent the only way that
well the only way anything is possible I
guess but the easiest way to go out is
if you have some kind of deal you have
something that could be sold to a big
company you have something that a big
company's infringing on and you can sue
them so it's like you have a gig of
legal fees or you have a big order lined
up with the company that's when an
investor wants to finance you don't want
to finance production they want to
finance market in expansion and so
really it's gonna be on you to get it up
and going unless somebody sees a
strategic advantage like if you have a
new way of making clothes and this
person's in the clothing business and
they understand it then that's a
potential fit for you but otherwise just
just funding an idea is not something
that most
investors want to do so you need to take
the concept a little bit further
actually get it up into production not
not mass production not where you're oh
who's our support okay fine no not when
you're what you're making you know
millions of dollars or thousands of
units right like mick ken and go sell
those and invest the money to make a
hundred and go sell those suck getting
momentum you want to show that you have
more demand for your product then 1 then
you have supply like you can't keep up
with the man because you have so many so
many things that's what you want to go
with that's where that's where you can
get an investor interested in it's not
just gonna be about it's not just gonna
be about funding the idea so that's what
I would suggest it's it's it's sad news
but you haven't done enough yet you've
invested you know in making the idea
it's great that's a great start but it's
not enough yet yeah right
all righty well and look at that I can't
say it now ok next question comes from
Ali and Ali says I'm not hungry enough
for new business any advice I'm not
hungry enough for new business I'm
assuming his new business any advice all
right so obviously hunger is something
like if you think about what hunger is
in life like you don't you don't really
I could be wrong maybe there's something
scientific
I'm missing about this but from what I
understand about my own body I'm just
hungry like I don't have to conjure up
hunger either I'm hungry or I'm not and
if I'm not hungry for something it means
that I'm not hungry for it and it like
you know and I would assume with with
business if it's like if you're doing
something you're not hungry for if your
business is if the idea of your business
is not pulling you forward every single
day in spite of whatever the obstacles
or you know even laziness all the things
that we can experience like the hunger
drives you really without you making a
decision for it to do that if that makes
sense so I would just conclude that if
you're not hungry for the business then
maybe one it's not the right business or
two are you trying to just create a
business because you think it's
something that you should do so I guess
I would just kind of question we've
talked so much on the channel about how
you know Evan believes in entrepreneurs
when he gets up in the morning he's
never not excited about it
even when I and I was just like I was
laughing you put out a quote recently
like being an entrepreneur sucks a lot
of the time however whenever we see you
doing what you doing you're even on a
hard day you're still bubbly about it
you're still excited and so I think
that's a good indication when even if
things are hard even when things like
are sucky your hunger to continue to
pull you forward because you're
passionate about it and and so I guess
it would be a good time for you to
rethink if this is the right business or
you know yeah and it just kind of comes
down to that what do you think
Jr is signaling be careful what is it
going back what's it doing ah you just
need a bigger why mm-hmm you know at the
beginning the why maybe you know you
need to you need to feed the family and
let me motivate you for a little bit
like this is where money is only your
motivation then as soon as you have a
little bit then things fall off so you
just need a bigger wife why is it so
important like everybody can be hungry
there's been times you've been really
hungry just for different things you
know I am not hungry enough to you know
I'm not hungry enough to be a
bodybuilder you know like I work out
when I'm not hungry enough to want to do
it more
I'm not hungry enough to be the world's
greatest salsa dancer mm-hmm right I'm
I'm pretty good but I don't want to be
the world's greatest at that I want to
be the world's greatest of something
else and so it just sounds like you have
some goals that are not motivating for
you you don't have a strong enough why
and might be better to go out and find
something that is more exciting and
interesting for you this has been times
you haven't motivated all of us has been
times when we've all been motivated I
don't think there's I don't think it's
just a matter of you know lazy people I
think it's just all of us have been oh I
don't think it's a matter of just being
a lazy person or not I think it's just
much more about having goals that are
interested in inspiring for you we've
all we've all had times where we've been
inspired and working hard and we've all
had times when we have been you know
today whatever you know just been kind
of lazy
and so understanding those oh we're
going to get a kill I didn't get I it
wasn't involved in it but the team got a
kill which is good so just have more
important goals like everybody can be
hungry just have a bigger why why is
what you're doing so important yeah and
can I just ask a here to follow up Evan
because I've been thinking about this
whole hustle concept right and I like I
like it but I think the part that I like
to include in it is that the hustle only
works if you love what you do I think
people can start doing stuff that they
don't like to do and then they are like
I got a hustle I gotta hustle I gotta
hustle and it becomes like it actually
becomes something that really works
against them because I think the people
who hustle are the people who are the
reason they're able to do that it's
because they absolutely love what they
do so I think I think sometimes people
take the hustle and they think oh I just
gotta hustle I just gotta like kill
myself doing this thing that I'm trying
to do because this is what I'm supposed
to doing so if the hustle but if you
don't love it if you're not hungry for
it if you don't think every day about it
like it's the thing that you really know
your stuff to do I think it makes the
hustle really hard I agree I mean I
think oh when they're attacked your eyes
watch it we are fighting
it's dangerous times for Evan we've got
a kill am I gonna die am I gonna die and
all right yeah team go team go go team
go
yes thank you
so hustle yeah I agree
you know I keep coming back to the Jerry
Seinfeld quote about the what's torture
for you or sorry what's torture for
somebody else's is not torture for you
you know the thing that you do you you
would do it because you need to do it
you know I've been I look at my youtube
videos and I want to do something that
is amazing and I'm you know I've just
spent the past two days working on a
Justin Bieber one and I feel it's really
important because a lot of people see
Bieber as somebody who is just a punk
kid who has nothing that nothing -
nothing good to add you know nothing
great to say and I you know that upsets
me that people feel like they can't
learn from him and it's like he's just a
symbol he's a symbol of all the people
that people feel they can't learn from
look getting into fights and so we're
like we did a video and and it was good
and I wanted to be better so I've spent
the past you know two three days working
on it maybe more it's a lot of work why
like why the support is Justin Bieber
gonna see it maybe you know did he ask
me to do it no it's just I feel it's
important like that's simple for me is
important and most people would not put
in the work that's needed most people
wouldn't do the work it's just too much
work it's crazy yeah but why do I do it
I don't know because I feel it needs to
get done and so hey that's why I put in
the hustle and so
you know you when you when you are
attached to the cause when you're on a
mission when you're doing something
important then you yeah you're willing
to work harder it doesn't feel like like
does it feel like work
yeah but again it's work that I like I
want to do it you know I feel it's
important so as much as this work it's
also pleasure
you know like I'm so proud of what is
gonna come out of this and I'm really
proud of the results so we're gonna
start hyping up the Justin Bieber top
ten rules video a little early stay
tuned guys coming
how would they city but maybe this week
we're probably early next week yeah it's
been happening a lot lately you getting
really intense review everything myself
and I always you know
pour some love into things mm-hmm but
you haven't know like even the Tyrese
one was one that I just felt like he
deserved more I felt like mmm I felt for
the the you know he's he's a different
dude and the way he goes about
explaining things and acting is very
different than most and so hmm I felt
like he deserved it to do something that
was different than what our normal
process was I felt that one day our
jungler died but I didn't expect it to
be a great like I didn't expect it to be
a friend fantastic video in terms of
views cuz I don't know how well Tyrese
is known you know I mean he's he's he's
a he's a well-known guy gasps but not
compared to some of the other people
that we've done I just did it because if
I felt like it's the right thing to do
yeah like that's when you grind that's
when you hustle when you feel like
you're doing something important mm-hmm
so you just need a bigger line like
maybe you're doing the wrong thing
that's fine
explore find something else till you
felt like you've we've all had those
times where you can't wait like you
don't want to go to sleep or you're
sitting in front of the computer working
and and whoa big time fighting happening
here that was a terrible teleport you're
sit in front of the computer and you
know you didn't realize how much time
has already gone by because you're just
working you're just you know we've all
had those moments where we get lost in
our work everybody and so that's what
that's what I want people to experience
more
yeah gimme chaotic here chaos happening
in the game but we're waiting we're ten
and eight so far so this is this is fun
let's see how we do keep going
what's our what's the next question okay
our next question today is coming from
another ollie so we've got ally and his
question is hey great videos I guess I
should clarify too because I know the
two people might come back and listen to
their responses so the first Ollie was
ali-a and the second Ollie was ollie
n as in Nancy all right so this is Ollie
and hey Evan great videos I'm currently
in the last year of my school I'm a
pre-medical student but I don't want to
be a doctor I'm always intrigued by
business can you suggest whether I
should give my o-level papers for the
science subjects or choose business
instead and give it and give its papers
we still have eight months to our C II's
all right do I need to read that again
for you
Eman is that clear I know I don't know
what Oh level papers R or C II's but I
have sue mitts technical terms for
medical field or school education and
that sort of thing okay
so whether to continue on in med school
or or go into business is that one thing
yeah yeah exactly yeah
so I love it I think if you have an
opportunity to first of all I think
that's just I'm sure that's very
daunting to go all the way through
you're pre-med you're pre-med go all the
way through your last year of school and
kind of be questioning you know
I don't even know if I want to be a
doctor and I really actually like
business so I just want to kind of
acknowledge that first because I know
most of us can go through that we invest
our time or energy in into something and
then discover that it might actually
actually be what I want to do and that
can be scary but I just want to
encourage you and say even if you do
decide businesses where you want to be
you know nothing nothing is really lost
you probably have gained tremendous
amount of skills and education and
knowledge that can then be applied to a
business so that's something to keep in
mind if you're feeling really anxious
about that if you have an opportunity to
do business I would say yes absolutely
go for it
you know I don't know how that would
impact your medical goals your medical
school goals so I don't I don't really
know what the implications of you
deciding to do that would be but if it's
something that you feel you can do I
think it'd be great why not start
getting some kind of momentum in a
direction that might potentially be
where you end up anyway so I died but
I'm alive again homework coming back
it's a very dangerous thing to realize
that you're not passionate about
something and then continue on just for
the sake of continuing on just in
general are they still fighting that
we're fighting what's happening guys I'm
not a big fan of it I'm also not a big
fan of just again as I just talked about
before burning the bridges and going all
in on on switching paths what I would do
is I would I would continue on with my
medical studies while also trying to
figure out business you know I'm an
entrepreneur I'm I'm in business but
honestly the education that I got around
business didn't really help much for my
business so don't feel like to be in
business to be an entrepreneur you have
to go to business school at university
and have the degree cuz it doesn't
really mean a whole lot to be honest
but that being said you know if you have
an interest in something you you owe it
to yourself to explore it you may not
you know it's gonna be it's gonna be
harder in the future that you get more
responsibilities to be able to go and do
it not that it's not possible it's just
gonna be harder so spend the time to go
out now invest a little bit of your
energy but you could take extra classes
or even just drop in on classes just to
just to get a flavor just to get a sense
right even if you don't get a credit
just see did you enjoy did you like it
was it helpful
oh we're fighting no we're not fighting
I think that's to be important so you
know I think about this I think of Steve
Jobs you know dropping out of his
classes to drop in on calligraphy
classes and not even knowing how it was
gonna work out and then you know
obviously led to him having beautiful
fonts for when he had an Apple you know
with the Mac and came up with all his
computers and they had beautiful fonts
so that's it's super frustrating I get
it when like if you if you're in a zone
that you don't want to be in you're not
passionate about anymore and you feel
like you're just doing it because you
started it or you're doing it because
your parents want you to do it or you
know you don't have a great reason for
doing it really which that's a that's a
that's a not great place to be in and so
I would really encourage you to look at
alternatives just not again not going
all in on it just finding some way to
get started on this thing so that you
build the momentum towards it whoa we're
under attack but we got it yeah
until like you can apply that to
everything look look at the work that
you're doing look at the day-to-day work
that you're doing are you excited for
the work you know are you longing for
something else
the more days that you go through when
you said man this day kind of just
another day ho-hum you know super boring
I hate my life you know like that's not
it's not it's not great it's not it's
not a way to live you know I have I have
a video date coming up and I'm looking
forward to filming mm-hmm you know I I
still look forward to doing my youtube
videos 4000 videos later I still look
forward to doing my videos I'm excited
for what's gonna come I'm excited for
it's gonna come oh I'm really under
attack now with the channel I'm excited
for during on the film today like I'm
still super pumped by everything and if
I stop then I'll need to go and find
something else I need to go do another
thing that I'm excited by and I think
the key for me has always been small
tests like don't let something go so
long that you hate doing it that you
haven't experimented with other things
that you can do and then constantly
evaluate and constantly trying something
new and constantly trying to make things
better than what it was before you know
this this livestream here is an
experiment with something we tested and
we've Jillian we've enjoyed it we've had
some success of this so we continue but
there's been lots of other things that
you know don't do well that that you
know don't have results that don't have
success that I don't enjoy doing but I'm
willing to try it out once as a small
test experiment and then see I think
that's really important
absolutely that's what I got cool all
right so we got a good question in the
in the live chat and DeMatha is the most
of 50 feminists asking any good streams
set for tomorrow Evan for your hangouts
oh that's a great question
probably I don't know you find out dad
pretty much yeah
I have no idea but beyond this it'll be
on the live channel I don't know if we
have anything on the mean you know yeah
I have no idea
I mean one of the one of the most
frustrating things for me with my
schedule was booking everything and so I
hired an assistant to basically booked
all the stuff for me and so the pros of
that are everything gets done the cons I
don't really know what's getting done so
I don't get into it yeah I don't pay
attention to it at all until really the
day of so I'm gonna be looking at it
tomorrow and seeing what we have but yes
I know there are some hangouts I have a
coffee meeting I have a phone call but I
have at least one hangout so we'll see
what it is
yeah and for those of you who just don't
know I heard weird quote but a weird
echo I started my echo is insane right
now for those who don't know if you want
to tune into Evans lives hangout and he
does have now his own separate channel
specifically for his live hangout and so
make sure you do a search for Evan
Carmichael lies Evan Carmichael live
it's a second channel and yeah that's
where you can tune in for his his live
stuff and
whoo-hoo Eman already had a 111
subscribers now that was part of my
gratitude stream yesterday that we hit a
hundred subscribers so working our way
up my yeah baby my big chain on YouTube
what's up yeah
like Evan gets a hundred thousand two
days while the rest of us play for years
well we won they surrendered so this is
the second pretty name
yeah they surrender it's a pretty fast
game again so this new strategy is kind
of working out here so I'm just looking
at my life channel we have one scheduled
tomorrow at 4:15 p.m. Eastern so if you
guys are here for 15 Eastern tomorrow
otherwise tomorrow I'm just I'm gonna be
in meetings i phone calls i have
meetings so yeah most of us it's happy
and it's sad I love the like marathon
marathon livestream days 9 live streams
interviews when I also love like the
one-on-one coffee I Who am I meeting
tomorrow for coffee I was someone who
wants to join my mastermind group for
coffee I'm talking to the Google someone
at Google tomorrow because they want me
to do don't wanna fly to New York to do
to talk about the book they do this
Google interview talks so he's gonna
interview me about my book at Google and
I guess it gets broadcast or I don't so
the YouTube channel or podcast or what
but we're looking at January to fly out
there and so I got to talk to the guy
tomorrow and talk strategy or whatever
he wants to talk about yeah and then
just a bunch of other meetings and calls
and stuff but one hangout one hanger
tomorrow 4:15 p.m.
can I get you the topic let me see the
topic how to build and grow a YouTube
channel
exciting but it's not it hasn't made you
know I'll make a public right now you
should go in on the day of but I'll make
a public right now for you new future
builder so you guys can go check it out
and subscribe and get notifications for
that live event and hopefully I will see
you guys tomorrow on this pop that up
and public and publish alright it's
official you know the live channel and
check it out
cool well another victory I'm pretty
pumped pretty excited you anything else
we need to uh any shoutouts or anything
else we need to go over resi before the
final reason wanted it there that's
that's it we're good here all right so
the final Ricci thought of the day is
all right well I'm just gonna leave you
guys with I felt like most of the
questions today had a lot to do with
your why and you know I want to do this
should I do it and all of that so I'm
gonna say what makes you bubbly because
every time I see Evan do his thing he's
bubbly and then I was watching I was
watching another youtuber I don't know
if you know dottotech he thought he does
a lot of about tutorials about around
technology and thinkin he was explaining
Infusionsoft which is a very intense CRM
software but he was he was bouncing in
his hair the explained this extremely
confusing software and I realized you
know when you love something you're
bubbly about it so what makes you ugly
type of bubbly everyone what makes it
bubbly all right I like it
cool well thank you guys so much for
watching that's it for us today we will
see you again tomorrow morning for the
gratitude livestream in the business Q&A
and then the 4:15 p.m. Eastern YouTube
hangout Rishi
Jerez and I all believe in you we hope
that you continue to believe and
and rise in yourself that's it much love
guys we'll see you soon what's left